All right.
So, yes, we have to talk about it.
The Donald Trump's health story has gone mainstream.
And I want to be really careful with this
story because Donald Trump is denying something
that has not actually been alleged and that
is extremely suspicious.
But I don't want to be alleging that thing.
I think you're going to understand momentarily
here.
So over the last several years, there have
been general health concerns about the president.
What's going on with his cognitive state?
You've got these twitches and spasms that
coincide with verbal glitches.
You sometimes have upper trump and sometimes
down or Trump.
He often seems confused.
He sometimes slurs without a real explanation.
We've seen him dragging his right leg while
walking.
We've seen Donald Trump sort of unable to
just speak normally, talking about the oranges
of an investigation and so on and so forth.
And then we had in 2019 that abrupt visit
to Walter Reed Hospital, which we were told
was merely Trump deciding on on a weekend
that he had a few extra hours in his day.
So he would show up at Walter Reed and get
a jump on when he didn't pass the sniff test
at the time.
Well, there is a new book coming from New
York Times reporter Michael Schmidt, which
says that visit to Walter Reed was not Trump,
saying, let's get a jump on my physical.
That it was some kind of abrupt visit due
to something medical that happened with Donald
Trump.
And it was serious enough that Vice President
Mike Pence was told Trump may need to be put
under anesthesia, be on standby in case you
need to take over for some period of time.
Those are the allegations from Michael Schmidt.
So these suspicions always were Trump wasn't
there for his physical and the book claims
to corroborate that.
Now, this would not be typical if Donald.
It wouldn't be typical for Mike Pence to be
put on standby in case Trump has to be put
under anesthesia.
If Trump's really going for a physical, that
wouldn't be normal for a physical.
So that's so far OK.
There's been an allegation made that that
visit was was it some kind of medical incident?
Donald Trump tweets out of nowhere that he
hasn't suffered mini strokes.
Now, you might say, why is Trump tweeting
about mini strokes?
Michael Schmidt didn't say anything about
mini strokes.
Well, that's exactly the question.
Donald Trump tweeting, quote, It never ends.
Now they are trying to say that your favorite
president, me, went to Walter Reed Medical
Center, having suffered a series of mini strokes,
never happened to this candidate.
Fake news, perhaps they are referring to another
candidate from another party.
Now, this is this information.
It has not been alleged that Trump has been
suffering many strokes.
Let me be clear.
People on Twitter have alleged it.
But the point is, it is not part of Michael
Schmidt's forthcoming book that Trump suffered
mini strokes.
Trump is out of nowhere saying that something
didn't happen, which no one has alleged.
This would be like if someone went to the
hospital and you say, hey, did did you go
to the hospital for routine blood work or
did something happen?
And you say, I didn't have a heart attack.
I definitely didn't have a heart attack.
It would raise suspicion if you start denying
something that wasn't alleged.
And in fact, it raises more questions than
it answers.
Now, I got an e-mail from Daniel, who's a
viewer who says, my mother is a board certified
neurologist.
I showed her a few clips of Trump's foot dragging,
slurred speech, etc. and she was fairly certain
he had a mild stroke recently, possibly the
night he was rushed to Walter Reed Hospital.
So when presented with some of the video of
Trump, you can certainly find medical professionals
who would who would ask about something like
a stroke.
But it is not actually what the book alleges.
Now, we also regularly see video, as is mentioned
in the email, of Donald Trump walking and
kind of dragging his right foot, not picking
it up completely as he walks.
It is true that such video exists, but again,
it is not proof of anything.
So here's my take on this.
We should be careful not to claim anything
happened when we don't know that it did.
Yes.
The visit to Walter Reed was weird.
It never passed the sniff test that Trump
was getting ahead on his 20/20 physical.
Yes.
Trump bringing up strokes when they haven't
been mentioned is extraordinarily odd.
But we really need to get actual answers about
why Donald Trump went to the hospital.
And if it was for a physical, there would
be no reason that he would be placed under
a..
That that he would be expected to go under
anesthesia and there would be no reason for
Mike Pence to be told be at the ready.
So it is gaslighting for Trump to deny having
a stroke because it hasn't been alleged.
And yet it is suspicious that Trump is focusing
in on strokes, particularly since it's not
something that has been mentioned.
So it would be great if at some point, because
I do think that as a general principle, the
voting public has a right to know about the
real health status of people who may be arguably
the most powerful people in the world or among
them.
I do think the public has a right to know.
And the White House should just come clean
about the reason for that visit.
Adding fuel to the fire of suspicion is that
when asked about this Mike Pence, his answer
was, it was certainly squirrely, slippery.
Let me put it that way.
And that's what I want to talk about next